[Music]
hello and welcome to high school
memories a show dedicated to exploring
the vital topics that significantly
impact high school students I'm your
host W and today we we are delving deep
into an issue that resonates with many
of us which is team mental health in
high school so in this episode I am
aiming to provide a comprehensive
understanding of the factors
contributing to Teen Mental Health and
challenges and offer practical
strategies for promoting mental
wellbeing so understanding the CH these
challenges in high school the world can
often feel like a pressure cooker
students face a mult multitude of
challenges from rigerous academic
demands to the pressures of
extracurricular activities and the
complexities of maintaining a vibrant
social life all these factors can have a
profound impact on one's mental
health and it's not uncommon for
students especially these days to
experience stress anxiety and in some
cases even depression
the constant comparison with peers on
social media platforms only adds to this
Trin
so let's take a closer look at the
factors that contribute to these
issues the pressures of academic
performance uh the weight of peer
expectations and the ever looming fear
of an uncertain future can feel our
Rance for students and many of them face
the challenge of finding a balance
between schoolwork extracurricular
activities and also maintaining a social
life too the constant connect
connectivity through digital devices
while offering many benefits can also
lead to a lack of sleep or and an
environment that never seems to shut
down and always proving nowadays so how
can we as high school students promote
mental well-being so I personally think
communication is key talking openly with
friends family or school counselor can
make a significant difference sharing
one's struggles and feelings can help um
Elevate the emotional burden but it
doesn't stop there because because
engaging in self-care practices such as
regular experience and mindfulness can
contribute to a balanced and healthier
state of
mind taking a few moments each day to
focus on your well-being can yield great
results in the end of the day week or
even year of practicing it additionally
we must work collectively to reduce the
stigma surrounding Mental Health
by making it more acceptable to discuss
and seek help for mental health issues
we can create a safer environment for
students to address their colleges and
to be more open with it safer
to communicate with
someone now I would like to share a
selection of essential resources for
those who might be going through a tough
time uh sometimes reaching out to a
professional can be intimidating so we
have some
Alternatives if you feel uncomfortable
going to a psychologist consider
starting with some helpful self-help
books like the anxiety workbook for
teens and the self-esteem workbook for
teenss by Lisa and shed are excellent
choices these work would provide
practical experiences and strategies to
manage anxiety a common challenge for
teenagers we have also a different
variety of books and they also which
also offer guidance on building
self-esteem and improving self
confidence if you prefer more digital
approach uh there are apps designed to
support your mental health Journey you
can explore apps like hatcap or call
which offer guided meditation and
mindfulness exercising to reduce stress
and anxiety which can help you from day
one to gain this skill and to also
maintain it in a daily basis the key is
to take action and explore these
resources to find what works best for
you if it can be a book uh digital
approach talking to
someone going to a
psychologist so it's best for you to
take Works uh and actions
done and thank you for joining us today
on high school memories I sincerely hope
this extended discussion on Teen Mental
Health in high school has provided
valuable
insights into this uh critical issue
that we
face if you are someone you know is
struggling with mental
health I recommend don't hesitate to
reach out for help your well-being is of
the utmost importance in this stage of
life especially and there's a community
that cares for you and remember that
you're not alone and there
are resources and people ready to
support you through these challenging
times so stay strong and take care of
your mental health thank you